what I love is you take all these that's
what I love about physics in general you
take all this complexity and you think
about what what are the basic elements
here how can I model people let's forget
about the emotions let's forget about
the biochemistry let's forget about all
that let's just think about them as a
particle that interacts with other
particles and what can we get out of
that and what they get out of that is
that in these circumstances at least
humans behave like gas molecules stupid
dumb gas molecules so that's whatever we
look at that's a pretty neat result
yes I've got a paper called with them
just the absolutely wonderful title of
collective motion of marshes at heavy
metal concerts it is indeed a physics
paper now I just found out from Jessie
who's the first author on the paper so a
few minutes ago by email to find out
that it's actually been accepted in a
very very good physics journal called
physics Physical Review Letters so it's
great to see metal appearing in these
type of journals it scripts to see those
links between metal and physics being
forged I'm a huge huge heavy metal fan I
think you could do an entire at least
one module maybe two modules on the
physics of heavy metal and particularly
with regard to the uncertainty principle
things called Fourier transforms signal
of processing the links between the
sound of a metal guitar and what the
waveforms look like and there's a very
very intrinsic and real link I'm not
making this up there's a real link
between the sound of a heavy metal
guitar and the Heisenberg uncertainty
principle so this is just a wonderful
paper well what they've done is they've
analyzed the behavior of Mosher's sorry
I guess we'll explain what Marshalls are
first of all so if you go to a heavy
metal concert and one thing that happens
a lot is that there tends to be a lot of
let's say physicality there's a lot of
people moving around there's a lot of
people bumping into each other you get a
lot of what's called marching with
people moving around doing motions like
this running into each other
you also get things called circle pits
where huge motions of people run
counterclockwise it's a fascinating
problem in terms of the dynamics of
human beings and there's increasingly a
lot of work on taking humans and instead
of treating all that complex biology
reducing them to that reduce them to a
particle that moves around that can
trace a particular trajectory you look
at its velocity you look at how it
interacts with other particles and
cryodynamics is a very very calming and
increasingly important aspect of physics
and of course it's really really
important when it comes to the dynamics
of how crowds move
you said people can be treated as part
of coarse particles haven't got minds
you can't talk to a particle and ask it
to stop particles don't care about
hurting other particles how can you
treat people indeed but you can model
all of that you can model all those type
of interactions so even for pedestrians
if you have pedestrians walking down the
street there tends to be sort of
exclusion zone your personal space
around you that other people don't want
to invade so what you can do is model
that as a sphere of influence basically
you can even model the the sort of
tendency for people to flock together as
a flocking force you can build that into
the equations and you can model this
entire system and in many cases the
parallels with fluid dynamics are
striking particularly in terms of
bottlenecks and jamming and when it
comes to traffic flow as well queues in
supermarkets all these type of things
remarkably you can reduce to two very
simple at one level physics and very
complicated in many other level physics
so what this paper has done is it's a
very very neat idea and it's not I don't
find it surprising at all that it's made
its way into Physical Review Letters
what they've done is if the one
difficulty is you want to look at the
interactions of people particularly
you're concerned about the safety of
people and the safety of buildings and
how you you might be able to engineer a
building or choosey architecture or
change the way the people move around
the building you you really need to
focus on how those people are streaming
or how they're moving and in many cases
people tend to move in a non panicked
relatively sedate fashion but not at a
metal gig at a metal gig there's an
awful lot of adrenaline there's a lot of
gnaw for a lot of people running around
so that gives you insight into the
physics happening under those type of
yeah there's no other word for extreme
circumstances and that's what they've
done great idea it also helps that on
both very big metal fans of course and
they've model it and what they find it's
so neat is that in mosh pits where
people are doing this this motion with
are moving around maybe an auto stand up
they find that you can model that
exactly as you
an ideal gas in terms of molecules
bumping into each other
repulsive interactions no real
attractive interactions because the last
thing you want to do in a matter of gig
is get too close to somebody unless you
can't push them what they find is that
they I don't wanna get too much into
graphs etc but this is just a fantastic
result is that when you look at the
velocity distribution of the velocities
of people if you look at the range of
different velocities that people have
and plot that out as a graph it's what's
called the Maxwell Boltzmann
distribution it's exactly exactly the
same mathematically as the distribution
of speeds you get in a gas they got lots
and lots of YouTube videos and just sat
down and analyze those wrote some
software to analyze those and looked at
the motion of people and then did loads
and loads of statistics and just it's so
neat it's really really really cool way
of doing research so because you're
looking at humans under pretty extreme
circumstances of the metal gig the great
thing about this is that you're getting
a different environment than anybody's
ever really looked up before and that
allows you to think about well safety or
how do you really look at the monitor
this situation think about how you would
get people out of a building how you
would ask in a disaster yeah so or if
you know in terms of you know a football
stadium if there's a huge rush for an
exit how do you get people out and is
the best way actually to sort of have
lanes of people or what where did those
lanes of people go which route do they
follow through the building to what
extent of people going to sort of follow
the leader
how can you break that up if that's a
problem how do you avoid bottlenecks all
of these type of things what's great
with this is that it's looking under
it's looking at those problems in the
context of very extreme human
interaction a mush pit does strike me as
a very different environment to humans
in an emergency where they're trying to
attain a goal and there's safety
involved whereas in a mosh pit it's
almost like there are no objectives
other than to just be kind of chaotic
and anarchy it doesn't it seems
different
I don't I'm surprised it's applicable so
there's something called Marsh pits
where it's exactly that you've got very
random motion but you all
of something called circle pits where is
a huge swell a huge collective motion of
people running around in circles
interestingly almost exclusively in one
direction which is something maybe
allude to in the paper which they don't
really understand which I find
fascinating
so in huge circles and then you've got
collective dynamics then you've got to
think about well who really is the
leader who instigates is who is this
nucleate how does this type of well how
do you get a fierce transition from a
mosh pit to a circle pit how does that
happen because that is telling you an
awful lot about collective dynamics
which I think I choose my words recur
but I think there's no reason to expect
that you won't be able to pour that type
of idea across to rather less extreme
circumstances
I despise Marsh pets my wife girlfriend
at the time
Daniel got our teeth kicked over mosh
pits I think this is a great
investigation
I think the physics is is really solid
and robust it's a really interesting
problem but I really hit mosh pits I
know that's not going to do me any
favors and win me any fans and the metal
fraternity I'll stress again I'm a huge
metal fan I'm a huge fan of bands like
Slayer and Meshuga and Fear Factory very
very hard-edged metal you know hardcore
metal and it pisses me off if I'm
allowed to say that maybe beardy can
bleep it out but it really irritates me
that I can't go to a gig wife paid my
hard-earned bloody money and watch the
band without having to continually do
this as a pit opens up in front of me um
it's it's always been a frustration and
this is not because I'm some old
middle-aged grumpy old git now even in
my 20s I despised it similarly with a
crowd surfing it just irritates me and
quite a few the bands I really like
bands like for example slightly less
metal but bands like Pearl Jam and also
the mars volta band called consolidated
they actually said right we're not going
to have marching you know I don't think
you can argue with the fact that people
have died because of Marsh pits so in
Dublin in the mid 90s shortly after I
left Oberlin to come to knotting a girl
died at a Smashing Pumpkins gig and you
know that's just ridiculous